le maire d'elancourt en campagne aux
côtés de sa deuxième adjointe jean
michel fourgous et anne capio pour
représenter la droite dans ce scrutin
départementale sur le canton de trappes
qui couvre également les villes de la
verrière et d'élans quoi et sans
surprise le programme porte
principalement sur l'emploi mais aussi
sur l'éducation
impliqué dans le développement du
numérique à l'école dans leur ville le
binôme souhaite étendre le dispositif
oui parce que beaucoup de trac piste
m'ont dit c'est pas normal qu'on n'ait
pas le même système qu'elles encourent
pour nos enfants
donc message entendu oui on va leur
donner le même système qui était
considéré comme exemplaire en france de
2,2 d'elancourt plutôt qu'on voit les
trappistes qui se battent pour venir
elle en cours et c'est jamais facile
mais on va leur mettre le même système
qu'elles encourent la ainsi qu'à la
verrière à ceux qui se disent surpris
par cette candidature de jean michel
fourgous que l'on imaginait plutôt
vouloir reprendre en 2010 est son poste
de député perdu au profit de benoît
hamon le principal intéressé évoque une
nécessité pour aider financièrement les
villes du secteur
aujourd'hui
il ya un fx y financières de toutes les
communes et dans cette situation la
solution c'est d'aller chercher des
fonds dans d'autres structures comme le
conseil général ou le conseiller
régional
en attendant que des législatives et et
c'est vrai que donc moi j'y vais pour
aller chercher de nouveaux moyens sur le
canton de trappes cinq listes se
présentent et la gauche se montrent
particulièrement divisée la liste menée
par la divers gauche sortante janine
mari n'a pas reçu le soutien du front de
gauche et du parti communiste